you'll also notice in the sample code
that we have lines that call log e which
log error messages with the adv
command-line tool and with the device
plugged in you can type adb logcat to
see the debug and error messages that
are being printed to the logcat for more
details on the logcat options see the
link below another way to view the logs
is to use android studio if you click on
this green Android button it launches
the Android device monitor which
includes the DDMS tool that Rado
mentioned earlier then click on a device
and you can see that our app here is a
running process if you click on the
logcat tab then you see all these log
messages here which is what we saw with
adb logcat now try viewing the logs
yourself with either of those methods if
you do both then you get brownie points
check this box to proceed